last november  and at the wedding the father the guy  that was getting married shows up to me  and he gives me a hug and he starts  crying he says listen man i'm so glad  you got a hold of my son at 18 years old  because it because the teaching the  environment  changed so  i have kids i know eventually these kids  gotta go learn from somebody else for me  to be able to say my son is spending a  quarter with tom i'm like it's coming  from a place of dude that kid is gonna  come better so the idea of education for  parents needs to be i can't wait to meet  the final product of my daughter or my  son  but that's not the feeling today okay  however if you are woke left if you are  liberal and you are sending your kids to  uc berkeley guess what you are going to  get exactly what you were hoping to get  when the kids come out of college